[Music]
in one month i will celebrate my 10th
anniversary with my wife uh so far i i
must give the marriage experience five
stars out of five
i must because my wife might listen to
this
but also because it's actually true you
know i had the good fortune of marrying
a woman who's care caring faithful
intelligent talented good mother
nurturing joyful loving
uh she also believes in me and supports
me and my ambitions and that's one of
those qualities in a wife that a man
kind of takes for granted if he has it
until he realizes that lots of men end
up in marriages with women who doubt
them cut them down
belittle their their dreams
i've never had to worry about that with
my wife which is a good thing because as
you've noticed i come up with some
pretty weird schemes sometimes and she's
almost always game for it in fact
sometimes she's the one suggesting
the weird schemes and things i should do
all of these are positive qualities and
on top of it all i must say that my wife
is actually
also really hot which which frankly is
is a huge bonus
now if you're looking at me and
wondering how i managed to land somebody
with all of those
qualities
i have no answer for you i'm just as
perplexed as you are
but it's just one of the reasons why i
thank god every day that i am married
and another reason
is that being married means i'm not
involved in a dating scene today which
is great because that scene is abysmal
in every conceivable way now dating was
not easy
a decade ago when i was still in the
game but it was a walk in the park
compared to the situation today
it's probably never been more difficult
in modern american history anyway for a
single person to find the right match
and that may seem paradoxical because
it's also true that single people have
never had more choices
and that's exactly the problem
case in point a recent article on the
website studyfinds.org about dating apps
and how people use them
um and this this is important because
almost all single people today use
dating apps you know
tinder alone has 57 million users that's
just one app overall about 50 of the
population consists of single adults
which is a staggeringly high number as
marriage rates continue to plummet
and about 40 of adults use online dating
so you connect the dots there granted
unfortunately not all of those online
daters are actually single but we can
hopefully assume that the vast majority
are
so what is the actual experience of
using these apps
how do people use them
here's what the article says it says
online dating became a way of life for
millions of singles during the
chronovirus pandemic dating apps like
match.com tinder and okcupid are
responsible for 10
of the long lasting adult relationships
in america which is actually pretty low
considering how many people use these
apps
and as it turns out these daters aren't
wasting time when it comes to choosing
who to swipe right on a recent study
shows that users know within a second
whether or not to express interest in
someone else
so what makes someone choose to make the
move on a profile researchers say it
comes down to judging the book by its
cover
the attractive attractiveness of a
person is primarily what compels another
to swipe right the study finds within a
split second the user determines whether
or not they will
accept a date based on appearance and
even race
now there's nothing new or scandalous
about people choosing mates based first
on appearance appearance is important
and it's not a small or irrelevant
detail
yeah they say don't judge a book by its
cover but the thing about a book is that
you don't have to see the cover while
you're reading it you just you open the
cover and that's it
as for someone you're dating or married
to you have to look at that cover every
day
so it's good if you find it appealing my
wife has already outlined has many
wonderful qualities but i never would
have learned about those qualities if i
didn't find her attracted when you first
meet someone you aren't going to know
about their deeper truer selves
and whatever character traits good or
bad may be lying under the surface
those things come out in time doesn't
take a long time but it does take time
initially you're going to be making more
surface level judgments to decide if
it's worth investing that time
so that's not in itself the problem here
the problem is the sheer number of
choices
and how quickly the dating app user has
been conditioned to swipe through them
the problem is also the very act of
swiping i think there's something about
swiping through just doing this through
a series of human faces that makes the
whole exercise somewhat dystopian and
dehumanizing
yes the cover on the book matters
yes physical attraction matters is
important but these days people are
reduced to just a postage stamp sized
picture on a phone
and potential matches will give them all
of
one second before deciding whether to
relegate them to the junk folder it's
all it's quite degrading
not to mention fruitless
because there are so many people on
these apps and and because they're
designed in such a way to encourage
these split-second decisions
all that means is that you have to
browse through an enormous number of
potential matches an article in mashable
a couple of years ago quoting the editor
of a trade publication called global
dating insights says that the average
dating site user has to swipe through 7
500 profiles before having a meaningful
interaction
now that's not 7 500 before finding a
girlfriend or boyfriend that's just the
amount of swiping needed to even have a
meaningful human interaction with a
person
and worst of all because these apps
require almost no effort
and no investment
and no energy to use
they only encourage more of the sort of
meandering unseriousness that has
already made the dating scene difficult
and had made it difficult when i was
single a decade ago
swiping left and swiping right becomes
more of a game an end in and of itself
and the people who are on these apps
actually looking for meaningful
interactions for relationship for
commitment have to somehow sort through
this sea of people who only want to hook
up or maybe don't even want that maybe
they want to keep swiping and have no
real deep interest in human
relationships at all
perhaps because they feel that their
porn habit takes care of those needs
it's instructive that even the words
boyfriend girlfriend and dating
aren't as common as they once were
instead of saying you know i'm dating
this person you'll hear people say
things like uh we're talking someone
said to me recently when referring to
the person that we would have once
called his girlfriend
he said yeah i've been talking to this
girl for six months
six months and you're that's how you
describe it just talking
you haven't even graduated to any kind
of actual
human relationship yet
after six months of dating my wife
at that point i was calling her my
fiance because we were engaged
fear of commitment
passivity
men who will not take the lead in their
relationships
single people kind of meandering along
floating on the tide dating for no
particular reason with no end goal in
mind
too afraid to even call it dating all of
these have been major problems for years
they've been problems increasingly ever
since we came up with the idea of dating
to supplant the idea of courtship
that's really when the the train went
off the rails
the dating apps have only as i said made
all this worse they've poured fuel on
that fire though i'm not sure that fire
is the right analogy here because that
evokes
something that's burning hot with
passion and intensity
but passion and intensity are the
opposite of what most single people
encounter
out in the dating world right now
and that is why the dating apps at least
the swiping dating apps today are
cancelled
hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated